met up with this girl on Tinder we went
on three dates in 4 days we kiss that's
it then I brought it up to Graham Graham
investigates our Instagram finds a photo
with a guy and I click this guy's
profile and it had her name as his
Instagram bio with a heart I facetimed
her and I was like hey what's going on
with this she's like oh it's my ex we
broke up he's inactive on social media
Graham DM's the guy we call him and say
hey just letting you know I went on a
date with this girl what's the deal with
you and her and he's all
and he gets all Angry he's all we've
been dating for 2 years I bought her a
car I gave her thousands of dollars we
have been together in a loving
relationship sends me a photo of his
wall just Polaroids of them all on the
wall and he said thank you so much this
restores my faith in humanity restores
and both destroys the fact that someone
will go out of their way to give this
guy a heads up it's the bro code if
that's happening you got to let the
other guy know